Maja Wichrowska - Do the Right (to Left) Thing: Directional Content in React.
My name is Maja.
I'm a front-end engineer at Airbnb in San
Francisco, and I'm going to start this talk
with a fun fact, because that's kind of the
traditional way we present at Airbnb.
My fun fact for today is that I actually broke
my nose so fine, playing rugby, very expected,
so, if you notice these bruises under my eyes,
it's not just the jet lag, it's a bit of the
nose!
So, I'm here to talk to you today about right-to-left
languages, and specifically the infrastructure
we've been working on to support them at Airbnb.
I hope to answer a number of questions throughout
this talk.
First, why support right-to-left languages
at all?
Why is it hard to do so?
What tools are already available to us out
there?
Finally, how we ended up tackling the problem
at Airbnb with like a special secret bonus
deep dive into our CSS and JavaScript infrastructure.
The takeaway is that I plan to demonstrate
the steps it takes to get this screen shot
turn into this.
And I hope that you leave this talk inspired
to build in the same kind of support into
your apps, and help make a more connected
web, one that is accessible and available
to everyone in the world.
Jumping right in, before we built this whole
new infrastructure, it was important to consider
who we were building it for, and why it mattered.
Of course, I would be tempted to go back to
the title slide and like it's the right thing
to do, and walk off the stage, and be done
with it.
But I will delve a bit more into the details.
It's difficult to pinpoint an exact number
of languages written right-to-left but a huge
number of people speak, read, and write these
languages.
Arabic alone is the fifth most spoken language
in the world, with estimates from about 300
million to up to 425 million speaking some
variant of it.
Couple that with languages like Hebrew, Urdu,
Persian, and more, and you easily add another
250 million people in the world who would
benefit from a web in a readily supported
right-to-left languages.
Now, since Arabic is the most popular of these
languages, we have the most data internet
users and specifically on the growing digital
generation in the Middle East and North Africa.
Internet penetration in the Middle East is
actually higher than the global average of
51 per cent, sitting at nearly 60 per cent.
Some countries like the UAE and Qatar have
90 per cent of the population regularly accessing
the internet.
These aren't casual users.
40 per cent of what has been dubbed as the
Arab digital generation is on the internet
for at least five hours a day.
Now, taking a step back, even if you're not
doing business in the Middle East or investing
there specifically, Arab immigrants are spread
out all over the world.
There are normal forums on the web.
Four out of five all internet users speak
Arabic which amounts to - it's the fourth
largest language group.
The number of English speakers on the web
have grown about 600 per cent since 2000;
the number of Arabic speakers has grown over
7,000 per cent.
This is huge.
And what is more, at least 60 per cent of
these users say they would prefer content
in their own language.
It's so much so that there is actually a statistical
preference towards blocking and other content-creation
platforms which you can extrapolate as because
they want that native language content.
Only 43 per cent of the top websites have
that Arabic content.
The ones in the room are the ones who is move
the metric in a positive direction.
For most of our apps, it's non-trivial, so
which begs the question of course, why is
this hard?
If the problem was supporting basic Arabic
content, it wouldn't be a challenge.
We would assembly align everything to the
right and call it a day.
But, of course, Airbnb, like a lot of other
platforms, has a tonne of user-generated content.
The text is showed in the user's preferred
language, there's a good chance that reviews,
listing titles, descriptions, names, will
be in a different language which creates a
by-directional text - a bidirectional text
environment.
Even if we could control the language of our
content, Arabic, Hebrew, are bidirectional
by default, numbers read left-to-right creating
a challenge in the simplest of information.
Bidirectional inputs are trickier.
If you have to handle input in every languages,
that - do you justify the input according
to the page's content language?
Do you decide on the fly based on which character
the user inputs?
What about pre-fixes and sufficient fixes?
How do you - suffixes.
How do you address mixed content?
There is a ton of open questions as to how
to create the best user experience.
When you add a little bit of directional styling,
even things like floats, or padding, that's
asymmetrical, that needs to be mirrored too.
Finally, iconography and other images need
to be taken into account.
If the text is flowing right-to-left, it makes
that arrows, chevrons and other images need
to be method tide to disappoint - modified
to point in that direction.
What about IDs, or search icons, check marks,
universal symbols for accessibility.
There are so many icons that may or may not
be flipped.
We live with a ton of questions.
What became apparent is that we actually need
to allow for some imagery to stay in the default
direction, and then we need to flip some others.
So, in summary, for a truly comprehensive
system to support right-to-left languages,
we need to be able to have non-directional
content but bidirectional content on the same
page and on the same sentence.
We need to figure out how to allow users to
type in content in their preferred language,
how to allow custom styles to be mirrored,
padding, alignment, borders, things like than.
We need to have the same allowance for images
and iconography, and the ability to opt out
all of these things on a selective basis.
So the big question becomes how do we accomplish
all of this with minimal disruption to our
existing code base and our developer work
flow?
We can begin by assessing the tools that are
available to us.
The main thing at our disposal is this HTML
attribute.
It is not a new feature.
It is kind of the opposite of a new feature,
introduced to the HTML spec in 1999 and was
kind of designed as a one true thing to holistically
support right-to-left languages.
This means that the browser support is super
good - every browser supports it - but, unfortunately,
it was built for a very different web.
So, to time-travel back, look at a beautiful,
brutalist Airbnb.com.
We set the dir attribute on the top level
with great success.
Notably, this is designed to automatically
flip inline block content and tap similar
information.
So, in the simplified Airbnb design, we see
that everything is right-aligned as expect,
labels are on the correct side of their respective
inputs, and tabular data like our calendar,
or even the grid of experiences flows in the
right direction, which is what we want.
One thing to note, though, is that inline
information, like our header links, remain
in the same order even with the dir attribute
set.
This is due to the fact that the content is
written in English, and, actually, if we translated
this, it would flow in the opposite direction.
Another weird point that's on this page, due
to mixed content, looking at the prices on
our listing cards, we see that the bidirectional
algorithm has identified the prices leading
the class, and, as a result, in a right-to-left
page, that means it's on the right side.
If we translated this per person, it would
actually be okay, so you can imagine this
page in Arabic, pretty good.
So, our first step in a right-to-left layout
is to check this dir attribute on every page.
At the same time we set it, it made sense
to make that available down the tree to do
customisation if necessary.
Enter reactive direction.
One of my co-workers conceived of and implemented
this particular library.
It follows a basic structure that we've been
using a lot for top-level variables like break
points, or loading data, even our internal
brands.
Two main exports - a direction provider which
sets the direction attribute on kind of a
top-level node, and a with-direction wrapper
which consumes that direction as a prop and
sends it down to each of its child components.
So, in action, the direction provider is very
simple.
If we start with a basic "hello world" React
app, we assemble wrap the content to the direction
to rtl or LTR or if we - and set the direction
appropriately.
In practice, if we do nothing else, this just
sets the dir attribute on the root node of
our app.
Once it's set, we can leverage our value down
the tree by using the wrapper, and there becomes
powerful.
If we wanted to have a basic step incrementor
component with a chevron icon that we can
click and move our stepper forward, if we
just put the dir attribute on top, you see
it works in the right way, and because we've
styled these elements in an inline block fashion,
it will put it to the correct side of our
text but it's pointing in the wrong direction,
and if we want to solve this in a reusable
way, we want to create a direction, let's
call it icon chevron next.
By default, it returns the icon pointing to
the right, but if we wrap it and with direction,
we will get access to that directional context
and we can return a left icon in the rtl context.
So of course this changes the game.
If we reference this new and improved icon
and set a direction provider at the top, we
can easily have a separator that works on
every language with no problem.
So, with these basic tools at our disposal,
we wanted to investigate how many of our components
need to be wrapped in with direction and customised
according to that value.
Unfortunately, the answer was quite a lot.
The dir attribute only handles inline block
and tabular layouts, and a lot of our pages
were styled in different ways.
The most basic layout characteristics, the
fact that this bucket box should be on the
far side of the page, doesn't get - the book
it box doesn't get fix by the dir attribute.
We have to manually address all of these little
style tweaks and spacing and things like that
if we didn't come up with a better solution.
We didn't have the resources to deal with
that.
So, we started investigate automated options.
We found a number of open resource projects,
RTLSS, CSS - web pack, and even like - I've
lost all my slide.
All of these packages came with one major
caveat: they're all CSS packages.
We had been spending the past two years moving
away from style sheets, so none of these were
really helpful for us.
Maybe in 2014, when we had been relying on
an internal bootstrap-like framework but at
this time, it wasn't really relevant.
I'm going to go on a bit of a tangent to explain.
Airbnb had traditionally been Ruby on Rails
backbone style sheet.
But as we moved to a world of React, the style
sheets we had were still associated largely
with routes whereas our components were more
featured-based across multiple routes and
pages.
We also had a lot of generic class names that
were really hard to track down and grab for
which made is really difficult to determine
what component required which style sheet,
and which style sheet was still in effect.
This was like a particularly big one.
If you can't figure out if a particular override
or style is still being used, that ends up
in us.
Sending down an enormous amount of CSS some
of which is an app to the page you're looking
at, some of which isn't applicable to any
page under Airbnb and this is causing a big
performance issue.
All of these things coupled together led to
incident after incident.
I think I sent out six individual post-mortems
related to mistaken CSS style sheets so started
to consider other options.
The question we asked was how do we style
React components while minimising side effects
performance impact and implicit dependencies?
The answer foreign us, and I - the answer
for us, and I will emphasise is may not be
for you, was to couple styles with our components
and write our CSS in the React components.
The idea of CSS and JS had been hot around
the web for a while and there were numerous
paradigms out there already.
We were leaning towards the Conig Aphrodite
library and we will delve into the basics
of how it works.
With Aphrodite, you want the create method
with your definitions.
It could be on import, that first render,
but that needs to be accessible by your DOM
elements.
Aphrodite handles fancy selectors, pseudo
selectors, and that's a feature bit on a pluggable
selector handler which will be important for
us later.
What a Aphrodite does under the hoot is transpile
that object to something it can understand.
Notably, it hashes the key of your style and
creates a class name for it and then does
any special selector handling to generate
the actual CSS.
You reference these styles objects on your
individual DOM element using the CSS method.
And this in turn turns into a unique - this
in turn, turns into a unique class name.
What Aphrodite does is inject it directly
into the page as a style tag.
This is great for performance reasons because
it is only ever injecting the subtitle that
are actually being rendered to the page.
-- it only injects the styles that are being
injected into the page.
We also enjoyed the parity of these definitions
with React native styles.
But, since the greater open source community
hadn't landed on a CSS and JS solution and
still hasn't landed on one true solution,
we didn't want to write our thousands of components
using Aphrodite only to have to write them
again in six months.
One of my co-workers tried to future-proof
this idea of Airbnb with a package called
React with Styles.
The basic premise of that is that, no matter
what technology you're relying on, you always
write your components the exact same way.
What actually does under-the-hood legwork
of that styling is an interface, and most
importantly, you can easily swap that interface
out by changing what you register.
We have interfaces for Aphrodite, CSS, and
even hilariously ...
just in case you change your mind.
So, to write an actual component in that paradigm,
you start by importing these two functions,
and then the components are defined the exact
same way they always have been.
Instead of the binnable component, you wrap
it in with styles.
And styles can be defined in a very class-like
manner.
You can see the parity with how we why using
Aphrodite before showing through in this wrapper.
You can also easily reference top-level theme
variables that you have defined like colour
constants, or user sizes, which is pretty
neat.
Then, because we've wrapped our component,
we actually have those styles accessible to
us as a problem.
We spread them on to whatever DOM node is
needed using the CSS method which again you
can see the parity with how Aphrodite does
class names.
This method can take conditional statements
as well which is cool if you're trying to
do some fancy stuff based on props.
You can even it cannily pass in based on prop
values or something calculated.
This is actually an added feature of React
with Styles with these objects will get convert
the to an instyle tag which again is important
for later.
Coming back to rtl, after that lovely tangent,
the environment created by React with Styles
and Aphrodite proved to be both a unique challenge
and a great benefit to how we implemented
automatic style-flipping for right-to-left
context.
Even though we had to get creative with what
was available to us, having this abstraction
layer allowed us to its trait an experiment
in an isolated playground without touching
either Aphrodite or our own codebase which
was pretty cooling.
When considering how to flip in this environment,
we considered a handful which would inform
our own approach.
First, we would have to handle all directional
styles.
Things like margin, padding, text alignment,
floats, left-to-right positioning, transforms,
everything.
Second, and this sounds really big: we wanted
zero changes as to how our developers were
writing their components and didn't want to
have to make any changes to the existing codebase.
Third how style sheets needed to be handled
and the inline style objects we were dynamically
creating on Render.
Of course, we didn't want to have a huge performance
impact on our application while doing this
process.
So, attempt number 1.
Got to love the number 1 because you know
it is not the final one!
We noted a few things that kind of like informed
this attempt.
So, one, style sheet creation happens on import,
not on render.
This means when we call that method, we don't
have any access to React context or other
variables.
CSS method is a singleton global export, not
passed down through the props which means
it doesn't have any access to React context.
Objects passed into the CSS method are handled
at render time, not on import.
That's important.
We can, however, assume that all of our apps
have a top-level dir attribute set, so we
do have that available to us.
As we noted before, Aphrodite has a built-in
plug-in system to handle fancy selectors,
and we can create our own selectors through
this process.
So you, the gameplan was to leverage Aphrodite's
figure-in system to create descendent selectors.
Specifically, we would wrap our default styles
in the ltr context, and the flip styles in
the dir squalls rtl context.
It knows we added these - added these two
new keys we are looking at, and the most important
part of this is that we would search our generated
CSS for anything that looks like a class name
- Aphrodite doesn't give us a nice object
to work with, it just gives us a string - but
we do regec to find those and do each of one,
depending on which object we are looking at.
The effect of this is if this was passed into
our style-sheet creation method, what would
transform into, ah, is this output CSS.
And so, this isn't quite enough to satisfy
all of our requirements, if this selector
handler was all we did, we would have to rewrite
our styles to have this styles in them.
So, we wanted to monkey-patch the CSS method
to do all of this for us.
This method takes a list of styles as arguments.
It flips them up so looks at the Aphrodite
styles and the inline styles separately.
They go through the CSS call.
The inline styles get appended to a style
tag, and is to what we did was create this
helper method that would split apart these
styles.
We relied on a really excellent package called
RTL CSS.
JS handling the flipping for which keys are
appropriate for which context, and so we dumped
out this object output, and then we passed
it into the CSS.
With our custom handler, we are free.
With inline styles, it is a bit trickier.
They have descendent selectors, obviously.
We had to call the same direction method to
split those apart, and, if there were flippable
styles, we actually created a fake class name
for that situation in the same way that Aphrodite
does, and, otherwise, dependent on the style
tag just as always.
We had a decent amount of success with this.
We didn't have to change any of our components,
and we found our switch component, which is
all CSS would roll in the correct way, so
it was pretty good.
But a number of things cropped up that led
us back to the drawing board.
For one, descendent selectors don't allow
for content-switching.
As I mentioned earlier in the presentation,
we have a lot of user-generated content.
You might be looking at Airbnb in Arabic but
there might be a review in English, and we
need to be able to align that properly.
Second, descendent selectors coupled with
directional styles and directional styles,
things like border and border left trying
to override each other, actually led to a
lot of very strange specificity issues that
we began exploring and learning about.
And then finally, when we upgraded to React,
because we have server-side rendering in our
app, we started seeing whereas previously
a client-side renderer would win, there were
discrepancies that would manifest themselves
in really bizarre and like undebuggable ways.
So, we went back to the drawing board.
Looking back at our original requirements,
we made one small change which is that we
would allow changes to our components as long
as they were easily code moddable - moddable
and could manufacturer the script.
We made sure we could handle context-switching
but no specificity issues, so dependent selectors
were probably out, and that specifically,
there wasn't a server-client mismatch in some
occasions.
So, our new strategy was to create contextual
create-and-resolve methods based on direction.
This notably was a bit of a challenge because,
as mentioned before, these methods did not
have access to context in the beginning.
How this would look in our interface, whereas
before we would have just one create and one
resolve method that would have to handle on
everything, we split it up.
There's one for the left-to-right languages,
and there's one for the right-to-left.
For Create, this was super easy, for, like,
in a default context, we called style sheet,
create as normal, and the rtl context, we
simply flip the styles into the pack I suggest
and put that into - inline styles is a similarly
simple solution, we would just flip the styles,
so now there is no specificity issues, no
challenges between the two.
Pretty good.
And the way we made this accessible to all
of our components is, before we were creating
the style sheet on import, so, again, no context.
So we deferred it to the first renderer, and
then picked the appropriate create method
based on directional context.
We are assuming that our apps are all wrapped
in the direction provider.
But again, this doesn't consider dynamically-created
inline styles, so we also picked our CSS method
based on the same context.
And the difference now is we pass it in as
a prop.
So the main change 24-hour components, whereas
previously they were written like this, we
would now pull the CSS method from our props
and call it instead.
This is prettily easily code moddable, easy
to write a script that handled all of our
cases off the bat, and the effect is pretty
stunning.
With just a few changes to accurate calm,
we are about to -- to countercalm -- ecosystem,
we are go to get - we still haven't launched
but we still have a way of testing across
the entire platform but we don't expect to
run into too much trouble.
The journey has gotten us an enormous way
there, and we look forward to rolling out
these languages in the future and making Airbnb
a bit more accessible to people across the
world.
And, if you would like to learn more, I highly
recommend checking out a React with Direction
package, a React with Styles pack I suggest,
and the JSS and CSS package, and you can always
tweet at me if you have any questions.
Thank you.
[Applause].